il a bien changé le métro parisien en
plus d'un siècle d'existence et avec lui
son ticket d'accès jusque dans les
années 50 il fallait attendre avant de
le faire poinçonner il ya du lourd au
guichet de pénible recherche de monnaie
et d'âpres discussions au portillon pour
fluidifier la cohue souterraines il a
fallu sans cesse adapter l'accès aux
quais à la fin des années 60 pour
faciliter de contrôle des 4 millions de
tickets quotidien néo promu tourniquet
prennent du service les poinçonneurs
devienne automatique sauf fidèles de
faille de taille le même billet déjà
déterré peut-être qu'ils aient plusieurs
fois parce qu'ils ne redoute ni les
contrôles ni les contraventions pour
limiter la fraude
il a fallu en finir avec les petites
roues depuis 1973 de tickets dispose
d'une bande magnétique décrypter et
validé par ordinateur que peut-on lire
et bien tout d'abord le type du billet
ensuite la classe
ensuite est-ce qu'il s'agit du réseau
urbain c'est à dire de paris vient du
rer et enfin le prix du billet le
passager en a vu de toutes les couleurs
des jaunes des verts des violets des
blancs pour finir à moins que ce ne soit
aux oubliettes qui finissent des gens
1997 le ticket papier était voué à
disparaître au profit d'une carte à puce
il ya deux choses il y a la notion
d'abonnement et une réserve de tickets
exprimé en argent une carte rechargeable
qui comprend même un système d' alerte
qu'il est même prévue qu'en appuyant sur
ce bouton constamment le passager puis
déclencher une alarme en cas d'agression
le concept avait beau être novateur il
n'a pas dépassé le stade de
l'expérimentation pour voir la puce
débarqué dans le métro il a fallu
attendre 2001 et le déploiement
progressif du passe navigo
il se recharge à la semaine ou au mois
dont le but de faire encore passer plus
vite les passagers au tourniquet même le
laisser dans le sac ça passe directement
sympathique en parallèle qu'il y a
toujours le coupon magnétique blanc
infatigable l'objectif en tout cas de
fluidifier le passage aux tourniquets
est réussi quant aux resquilleurs tant
qu'il sera possible le dépasser au
dessus de la barrière sas facile jusqu'à
attention qui parle et comprend l'art
derrière la fraude n'est pas prête de
s'arrêter
elles coûtent chaque année 366 millions
d'euros à la ratp
[Musique]